Hello, everybody!
My name is Markiplier, and welcome to Horror of the Deep.
Now, this is an early access horror game,
and I BELIEVE it's got an element of randomiza-
Wow, you throw- you get thrown RIGHT in there!
Ooh...
And I also imagine there's some horror in the deep that I gotta see.
So did I fall down this well, or did I intentionally come down here... with no rope-?
I fell down here.
Is this the beginning of Batman--?
oOAAY, I'VE GOT MORE TO FALL!
Alright, hello.
Apparently, I'm going deep!
(barely audible) Ooh.
Alrighty then.
What do we got here?
Ooh!
(reads) "When you read this, you are already a traitor of your own ancestry.
Oh!
How nice!
(continues) "Like me and countless other outcasts.
"Death awaits those who turn back, slaughtering the weak and scared who dare to crawl back...
"Back into a kingdom that do not belong anymore.
"This is your world now, and down here Death is patient.
"He's s-
(hears stippy-steps)
-kulking in the darkness,
"reaching with his gory hands for the last thing that you can call your own.
"Mistakes will be paid in blood, and hesitation will be your end."
Eliphas.
But I like to hesitate and look back a lot!
It's like my favorite thing to do, so...
whuuuuuu...?
(sounds of encroaching evil)
(softly) Okay.
(door creaks)
Ah!
Excellent.
So... what about this?
So, where am I going exactly, and why?
So I've been outcast.
That much I've picked up on with my big ol' brain,
and oh my God, that looks beautiful!
Who built this shit? (chuckling)
Who built this outcast sanctuary down here in the deep?
Why do I always question that?
I literally- li-
WHO BUILT THIS?!
I thought we were underground!
Wait, what the fuck happened?
Okay...
It's like everything in Dark Souls.
Like, who built that shit?
Who built this shit?
How far down does it goo?
Ugh, I don't-
HEYYY F--
mmmmMMMMmmmmm...
(motorboats)
Mmmm'kay.
Alright, didn't expect that one.
Uh, "Come," "Wait," "We are watching."
"Come to us."
"Never alone anymore."
"Come," "Die!"
"We are waiting for yuuuh!"
Alrighty then!
Whatever yuh say.
(reads) "Many have been sent here to die and many will follow.
"Our fate has been predetermined by the wrath of the king.
"We are cursed to slowly rot in this lonely, Godforsaken place.
"But is this the end?
"I have the feeling there might be another destination for us all.
"Follow me into this forgotten place and I shall be light in your darkest hour."
Eliphas.
Why does he sound like the pastor from, uh...
Outcast-
Outlast, Outcast-
You know, my favorite game, Outcast.
I do not know...
but I like it so far.
I'm descending into the deep!
I thought I was alre-
oh, "The Atrium of Renunciation!"
(fake laugh)
I see you like big words too.
Me also am talk in big words most time!
Me like to talk and make me sound smart!
It real good f- fun pastime for me!
Where am I going?
Can I take one of these torches?
Oh.
Hello!
Any prisoners here--
ooOOooh!
Hey, sir!
How are you doing?
You being treated okay?
Are you a denizen of the deep?
(barely audible) Alrighty then. Ooh, blood.
(gasp)
Fucking Goddamn fuck you with your statue bullshit!
YOU THINK YOU CAN SCARE ME?! Fuck off!
Eugh, I don't like the face on you.
Not callin' ya ugly or nothin', but I'm just sayin' you're ugly as fuuuuuck.
Alright, what else we got here?
Anybody down here?
Anybody down here wanna mess with the likes of meh?
Oh!
More Eliphas knowledge?
(reads) "All this time this forgotten sanctorium was lying in the darkest veil of our lost ages.
"Inside the gloomy halls, a horrific death awaits us, but I have seen a glimmer beyond the madness.
"They don't know this place anymore like we do now,
"therefore this is the last trial before our new, true destiny.
"I can see it."
Eliphith.
Well, thank you Eliphith for your insight.
Oh.
I don't know if I'm going the right way, but I'm gonna keep plowing ahead.
Yeesh.
Hello.
Oh, good! "Death awaits you!"
I dunno if I like it.
Alright, nothing here.
Is the hesitation going to kill me now?
Is the turning back going to make me dead?
Oof.
Eee.
Kinda reminds me of... Amnesia: The Dark Descent, you kno-
(jumpscare)
HEYYY F-
(frustrated Markimoo noise)
Fuuuuuck!
Alright, fine.
That's how you're gonna be.
You're gonna spook me with a gas pipe.
Is that really how I'm going to be spooked here?
Well, I don't like that very much!
Oh.
A... BIG key.
A big HONKIN' big boy of a key!
Me likey the big boy honker!
Well, maybe Eliphas can give me some insight into why it's so much gas,
and where this place even came from.
But you ca- you can't deny; a little bit of Amnesia.
"3 keys will lead to your destiny."
"Pathetic."
Okay! Three, three, three. Got it.
I've got one of these keys...
Where's da ovvers?
Ooh.
Spider?
Spidey!
How you doin', spidey?
That don't look good.
I probably shouldn't step on that.
If I had to guess about that, that's probably not something I should step on,
judging by the dead body and that spider.
Hey, buddy.
How you doin', spider friend?
Ohhh!
Big boy skulls!
Man, everything's big boy in this place!
(reads) "Today, I woke up to the cracking noise of something stepping on a branch.
"I was prepared to stare into the dead eyes of one of those monsters and waited for my life to end.
"Nothing happened.
"I rolled cautiously to the other side and saw a slender man.
"He was bent over our fallen brothers and sisters, and seemed to be trying to remove their limbs.
"I stood up, prepared to fight the intruder.
"The slim man looked at me with his blood-red eyes, and disappeared laughing in the darkness."
That doesn't sound like the Slenderman I know!
You also seem very dead, so...
(clicks tongue) what do you know either?
I am the one who lives...
so I am the one who will find my way.
Nothin' over here.
So...
I take it the last key might be over here somewhere?
Uh- ooh, dere it is!
(light gasp)
Any traps?
No-no-no!
(key get)
Oooh, fuck you.
(statue makes noise)
HEYYY DON'T DO ANYTHING!
Righty then.
Carry on with your life...
and, uh, hopefully, uh, I'll never see you again!
Good! I got three keys now!
(door opens and music crescendos menacingly)
(music decrescendos as door opens fully)
I don't like that.
I don't like that at all.
Ooh, more de-
OOOOookay-
OOOHHHHHH!
"Auditorium of the Crip!"
Where's the Auditorium of the Bloods?
It's probably next door.
Eee.
Welp, can't-
ooh?
Nope, can't go out there.
Alrighty then.
Where am me am go?
What am me am do?
You am going- oh fuck.
Who BUILT THIS?!
Who built all this?!
Who built ALL of this?!
Who built that?
It's the only question that I've got, is who built that?
Ooh.
What is you?
I would ch-
wwwwWUuuuh...
Okay.
Ooh, what dis?
Hello.
(reads) "We are all banished from the lasting kingdom by the cruel, eager king from the highlands.
"A man who treasures his own wealth and power more than anything.
"A man who uses expelling and slaughtering in order to keep his precious, fraudulent hopes burning.
"Sadly, you could be one of the many peaceful souls who didn't deserve this.
"However, lamentations will remain unheard to eternity.
Eliphas!
Okay, thank you, Eliphas.
You're very eloquent, Eliphas.
I like the way you speak, Eliphas.
You got a good way with the word doing.
Alright, what else we got here?
Oh! More deep to dis-
Okay, I thought I was in the Auditorium of the-
Ohhhh, this is the Forbidden Crip!
Ooh, THEN we get to the Forbidden Blood!
Yeesh.
It's dark in here.
I don't know if I like that.
'Cause judging by the wa-
oh, "Help me,"
"Fear for the weak?"
"Please hurry."
I got a feelin' that sprintin' into this is probably a bad idea, but here we goooo!
Ohh.
Alrighty then.
Eliphas, give me some insight.
(reads) "Our, no...
(hears footsteps behind him)
FUCKING HELL WHAT THE FUCK I HEAR THAT!!
You heard stip-steps, didn't you?
I heard stip-steps, I'm not crazy!
I'm a little crazy, but I'm not crazy.
(reads) "Our, no... THEIR lands are now rotting like the rest of the world, they cannot stop their disease.
"They cannot stop the hate from spreading.
"Everything will be devoured in the end and their destiny will be no better than ours.
"Our bones will molder to dust and our souls will flee from this world.
"But the time has not yet come... There is hope for us in the deepest chasm...
"It is said that a group of outcasts has been able to form a new civilization deep under the Earth...
"Surviving at a place full of unknown threats of another time."
Eliphas!
Okay, thank you, Eliphas.
Your insight, as usual, is always appreciated.
(door creaks open)
Squeeak!
Ooooh, whaaaauuUUUUUUGH-
I don't like that!
Don't get up, please!
Who are you and why are you there?
(sound of soft sobbing)
Oh.
You're crying.
I like that even less now.
Alright.
Hello!
Hi!
Who are you and why should I be near y-
(creature starts screaming)
HEYYAHHH!!
OHHHH NO-HOOO!!
OH GOD!!
I have died.
I have done the dead!
Okay! So... quick answer to short answer;
don't go an- near anything that is crying.
Ever!
If you're ever in a horror game and something's crying...
kill it!
Just kill it!
Just be proactive... and kill it!
Oh, God.
Alright, let's try that again.
(mocking floor writing) Help! Oh, help! Oh no, help! Oh, help!
Yeah, I'll help you.
Speed you on into the afterlife, ya piece of garbo.
I don't-...
I don't wanna go ba-ack!
Oh, I GOTTA go in there?
Really, I gotta go in there?
(door creaks open)
Ohhh boy.
I'm just gonna turn and run as soon as it starts going.
(barely audible) I'm just gonna turn and run.
(scared Markimoo noises)
Not yet-
ooh!
What does that say?
(laughing nervously) Trust her!
Trust- trust her?
That's- (too quiet to hear)
r- AHH!!
Oh, no, not yet?
Oh, Goddammit, fuck you!
EHHH!
Ah, Goddammit, come on, you piece of shit!
(creature screams)
aaAAAAAAAAA-HA-HAAAAAAA!!
GHEEEE-HEEEEEEEEOOOUUUU-
AYYAYYAYYYAYYAYY-
No-no-no-no-
I'm not even gonna look back!
I'm not gonna look back,
I'm not gonna look back!
I swear I'm not gonna look back!
Oh, I'm gonna look back, aren't I?
OOH!
AAAAAHH ITS STILL THERE!!
OHHHHH NOOOOOOOO!!
(death occurs)
MMMMMMmmmmmmm...
This really does- that respawn even feels like Dark Souls... in a weird way.
God, if Dark Souls, you had no weapons...
huuuuuugh!
Fuck that thing.
Whatever that thing is, fuuuck thaaat thiiiiiing!
I don't wanna trust it,
I don't wanna know about it...
I don't wanna know nothin' 'bout it.
I think maybe I can go around it...
but other than that, buuuuuuuuugh I don't know.
If I can skirt around it, because it's-
it's pretty close that you have to get to it for it to be mad at you,
(barely audible) So I'm gonna scooch a little bit with my butt over here...
Just gonna scooch my butt-
Okay, you stay there.
Don't like that one bit.
Alright, what do we got over here?
Uhhhh, I trust neither of those options.
I'm gonna go with this option here.
Oooooh!
Oh, I don't like that.
Oh, I don't like this.
So why are there gravesto-
ooh, key!
Big boy key!
Alright.
Well, got that one.
Are there more keys that I need to get around here?
And why?
Yeesh.
(sing-song) Ooh, don't like this at all.
Okay.
I think this is gonna go above her.
Maybe?
Yeaaaah.
On the second level...
Hopefully I can get some solace.
Yeesh-
Oh, don't break.
Oh, don't break...
Don't break don't brEAK DON'T BREAK-
okay.
That would've been a douchey moment to break, but I think we're okay.
Where am I going?
Where-
Woah, woah, woah!
Okay.
Alright!
I love the coloring on this, by the way.
Just to talk about the game and not about my own fear for a second!
I just like it, it's very, uh...
well did.
Okay, you guys are dead. Why?
(door creaks open)
Ohhh!
Alrighty then!
Was that the only reason that I needed to come down here, for that key?
There must have been something else there, right?
There must have been something else.
I can't believe that there would just be one key.
Right?
Maybe...
I dunno
It's hard to say.
Yeeeugh, I don't like that.
Because I can't really go the-
uhhhh-
No, I can't really go the other way.
I might be able to sneak around her towards the back,
but there was also another way down here to the left.
I gotta remember that, and that probably opens the other door back...
juuust in case I need to book it out of here-
yeah, it does.
Okay.
So I gotta imagine...
if I go around her, I'm either gonna die or i- this is gonna pay off.
And I'm probably gonna die.
Okay, here we go.
I don't like you.
(barely audible) I don't like you.
(still barely audible) I don't like you, I don't like you, I don't like you.
You don't like me, I don't like you.
You don't like me, you w-
Oh, get off that rock!
I don't like you, you don't like me.
I don't like you... you don't like me.
Oh, we don't like each other.
We don't like each other.
We don't like each other very much!
Oh God oh God oh God oh God-
eeEEEEGH-
Okay, we're fine, we're fine, we'RE FINE, WE'RE FIIIIIIINE!
UUUUUGH, somehow we're fine.
What is that?
Oh, it's a Horror of the Deep, I know that, but what is that?
EUUUUUOGH!!
Ooh, no thank you!
I- no no no no no-
That's a no-no!
That's a no-no on that!
Ohhh, no-no-no-no-no-no- no no!
Well, there's no other way to go, is there?
Ooh, I'm just gonna go by you!
'Scuuuse meeeee, siiiiiiiir!
Oh, I need three keys AGAIN!
I see that three key door lock.
Son of a bi-
AAAAAH HEYYYUUAUUH!!
Fucking Goddamn it!
mmMMMMMMMMM FUCK YOU!
Ohhhh, I don't like this. Where am I going?
Ah, what am I doing?
I don't know where I'm going, I don't know what I'm doing.
I'm just lost and lost, I'm a babe in the woods-
is that a key-? Oh, I'm LOST!
No, it's Eliphas!
(reads) "There was a child in one of those halls.
"It was crying and shouting for help. No one you meet in this rotting hell shouts for help.
"Why would they?
"There's no one here to help.
"We decided to leave the child to its own destiny, and continued our way in safe distance.
"A crying child is loud.
"It would probably have meant the death for all of us if it even was a child."
Vasillis.
Oh, thanks for the advice AFTER I've already met this crying child.
Eugh.
Well, lucky for them that they mistrusted it.
I'm still lookin' for keys.
(sigh)
Finding lore AFTER you need the lore is always my favorite thing.
(sounds of monstrous demons)
MMMUugh, I don't like that.
Okay!
Just gonna skate on by.
Skating by, skATING BY, SKATING BY!!
No no no no nooooo!
No-no-no-
this is a dead end!
OOookay!
Alright.
Here we go.
We're fine.
Okay-
Where's the goddamn keys?
EEEUUuugh!
Goddamn keys are nowhere.
Goddamn keys are exactly nowhere!
Is there one here-? PLEASE tell me there's one here.
Ohhhhhh, it's just another-
Ooh, key!
Yes, okay.
Just one more to go, then.
Oh. Hello.
(reads) "Today, there was something that looked like another child. It was silent, crawling slowly in our direction.
"It seemed wounded. Our leader finally decided to help the wounded child.
"He was reaching towards the child,
"as the monster jumped toward his face and pierced his throat with its sharp knife-like teeth.
"He was dead before he could even react. May his soul rest in peace.
Okay, so I get it.
I'm not gonna let those things touch me.
No tooches from them to me!
I understand full well.
So if I can fi- oh...
OH NOPE NOT GOIN' THAT WAY!
Ohh no no!
I know about your knife-like teeth!
Oh.
No n- NOOOO Nn- no-no!
Okay- AH!
Okay, that's another one!
Ohhh, frick-a-dick!
OHHH God!
Oh no! Oh! Wait! Uh-
EUUUUUGH!!
This way.
Probably.
I don't like that!
HEYYYYY NAUUUU!!
OKAY!
Alright!
Okay, I didn't like that.
Hello?
"Don't go this way!"
I'm going this way, apparently!
OHHHH I'M- I REGRET THIS!!
I REGRET THIS IMMENSLY!!
There's no key in here.
Why did I go in here?
This is not a good way to go!
There's a lot of dead buOOOODIES!
Okay.
Well, this was a mistake.
"Trust me."
Yeah, you- (gibberish)
I didn't trust you before, but...
probably shoulda.
What's down this way?
OOP!
BRUUUUGH NOT THAT WAY!
Not that way!
That was a b- wa- a baaad way!
Okay...
So I gotta get around...
to the left there-
uuugh!
Okay, yeah, come this way!
Come on!
There's none of them down that way, right?
Come-come!
Come-come-come!
Okay...
you're slow, you're slow, you're slow.
I'm fine, you're slow.
(scared Markimoo noise)
Okay.
That should be enough berth... to be able to get by.
Alright, here we go, here we go-
oooooh, scoodly-doooo!
Scoodle-oodly-doo!
Okay.
We're good, we're good, we're good...
Okay, so there's gotta b-
Oh!
HEYYY- oh, it's you!
Okay!
NoNOnono!
No!
Nono! No!
Nooo!
No!
Nonono...
NoNOnono.
Okay, so there's gotta be one more around here somewhere.
I just don't know where.
Oooh, I just don't kn-
Woah.
OOOKAY, I d-
OHHHHHHH!!
It was a hole in the ground.
But I don't know if that was supposed to be there.
Okay.
So anyway,
I am actually completely out of time.
I, uh, can't- I, uh, I-
And I don't even know if this game is finished,
'cause remember, this game is... in early access.
Very early access.
But what they got going on here, right now...
Very good.
Very, very good.
If there IS more to this game, let me know down in the comments,
because this is really, really good, what they got here, so-
this has a lot of potential.
I was terrified at moments
And it really scared me... more when there was nothing than when there was something,
'cause... I didn't know what to expect, and that's really good out of a game.
I- in- in all honesty, like, even the character models,
you could tell they're a little low res, but still, it was scary.
So, let me know what you think.
Thank you everybody so much for watching,
and as always, I will see YOU...
in the next video.
Buh-byyyyye!
(outro music)